[Musik]
liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer zwei
jahre pandemie ungelöste klimafragen und
jetzt auch noch der krieg in der ukraine
all das zeigt uns gerade dass es
dringende veränderungen brauchte um
unsere demokratie und unsere werte zu
verteidigen und die zukunft als
gesellschaft aktiv mitzugestalten
wie kommen wir voran welche strukturen
und abläufe brauchen dringend ein update
aufbruch ist das thema für die kommenden
vier sessions unserer land schreie
rasender stillstand
die wir im bucerius lab der zeit
stiftung gemeinsam mit unseren partnern
holz bringt berlin und wissenschaft im
dialog für sie geplant haben heute
sprechen wir mit unseren gästen darüber
wie ein gutes digitales miteinander in
zukunft aussehen könnte wir bewegen uns
immer selbstverständlicher im virtuellen
raum und bei allem komfort sind wir dort
auch mit fake news hassrede und
extremismus konfrontiert was können wir
dagegen tun wir haben eine
schriftstellerin gebeten ein
zukunftsszenario für uns zu entwerfen
theresa hanich ist science fiction
autoren gerade hat sie ihren neuen roman
von topia bei fischer tor veröffentlicht
lassen sie sich jetzt von ihr für einige
minuten in eine digitale zukunft
entführen in der schon einige unserer
aktuellen herausforderungen gelöst sind
im anschluss sprechen wir dann mit
unseren gästen über die ideen die sie
jetzt gleich hören
mein name ist theresa harnik ich bin
science fiction autoren und ich
präsentiere ihnen heute ein szenario als
impuls für die diskussion viel spaß
orks büroarbeit und anhängliche kreis
mit voller wucht ließ an die streitaxt
auf den schädel des kaufmanns
niedersausen ein lauter knall und der
ort kippte nach hinten
fanfaren feuerwerk außerdem eine nicht
unerhebliche menge gold klärten inanc
ohren jubelschreie in unterschiedlichen
sprachen erklangen die teammitglieder
ihre abenteuer gilde führten einen
freudentanz auf aber an hatte keine zeit
mit ihnen zu feiern tut mir leid ich
muss weiter arbeiten sagte sie sehen wir
uns morgen auf der grand alliance for
future demo fragte ihr sohn robert der
jetzt die führung der abenteurer wilde
übernahm na klar ich freue mich sie
setzte die vr brille ab und
augenblicklich drang die reale welt auf
sie ein die war zwar nicht zum hell und
bunt wie die virtuelle realität dafür
aber massiver und durchsetzt mit den
gerüchen und geräuschen vieler menschen
an rieb sich die augen trat aus der
pausen kabine heraus und setzte sich
wieder an ihren arbeitsplatz
außer ihm befanden sich über zwei
dutzend künstler innen freelancer oder
angestellte im shared space büro sie
waren nicht bei der gleichen firma
beschäftigt wie an sondern wohnten in
der nachbarschaft statt im home office
zu bleiben suchten sich viele leute aus
dem quartier einen arbeitsplatz im
shared space unruhe oder kollegiales
miteinander zu erleben je nachdem wie
früher täglich ins büro zu pendeln
erschien ihnen als unnötige zeit und
geldverschwendung die allermeisten
besprechungen wurden sowieso als
meetings im metaversum abgehalten also
in virtuellen räumen in denen sich die
teilnehmenden lieber von einem avatar
als er im real bild vertreten ließen so
macht das auch nichts aus wenn man statt
business anzug nur ein t shirt trug ein
verschlucktes kind auf dem schoß hatte
oder der tischnachbar laut stadt flug
zuflucht
bild und ton filter machen das leben
leichter seit an dem rollstuhl saß
wusste sie diese möglichkeit noch mehr
zu schätzen die digitale welt war
wesentlich barrierefreie als die analoge
an verbrachte oft und viel zeit in den
künstlichen räumen nicht nur als kurze
verschnaufpause während der arbeit
sondern auch danach mit freundinnen oder
kollegen online offline oder hybrid
gemeinsam einen film ansehen ins museum
gehen zum cyber sport verabreden oder
ein konzert besuchen alles war möglich
das war für menschen mit behinderung und
auch für leute die sich in großen
menschenmassen nicht wohl fühlten eine
große erleichterung
und wenn ab und zu für ein spiel ihres
lieblings fußballvereins ins stadion
fuhr wusste sie robert an ihrer seite
der wir eher brille von zuhause
zugeschaltet war die grenzen der realen
und der virtuellen welt verschwimmen
zusehends dadurch verloren entfernungen
in der physischen welt an bedeutung alle
menschen waren sich sofern sie es
wünschten durch ihre visuelle präsenz im
metaversum gleich nach außerdem gab es
filter mit denen sich das
empörungspotenzial bestimmter themen
dämpfen dies da das erleben der
künstlichen realität so viel immer sie
war als die traditionelle nutzung des
internets dienten sie als schutz vor
trollen virtuellem scrolling oder
endlosen diskussionen junge leute
bevorzugten eine unzensierte
wirklichkeit aber an kannte ihre träger
und ließ sie vorsorglich ausblenden auch
das problem der fake news auf die spitze
getrieben durch die pcc videos wurde
durch den einsatz von ki gesteuerten
filtern und block c news follow ups im
zaum gehalten
datensicherheit und daten freiheit
rangen stets miteinander wie in jeder
guten demokratie die neue digitale
gemeinschaft war konfliktfreie und
freundlicher als das alte 2d internet
offenbar übte der kontakt von angesicht
zu angesicht und seines nutzbare die
gleiche soziale kontrolle aus wie das
reale zusammenleben
vielleicht lag es auch daran dass mit
der allgegenwart der digitalen
doppelgänger äußerliche schönheit
endlich zu einem standard für alle
geworden war ein umstand der erst wieder
in der analogen welt für probleme sorgte
um sich vom mainstream abzuheben konnte
sich jeder individuelle badges an seinen
social media profile anheften an zeigte
mit stolz das abzeichen ihre abenteuern
außerdem macht es ihr spaß virtuell
gewebte stoffe als accessoire für
avatare anzubieten manche designs
verkaufte sie andere stellte sie
kostenlos zur verfügung und erhöhte so
ihr community kammer konto andere leute
zeigten in ihrem profil ihre netzwerk
matrix ihre prosumenten zertifikate oder
ihre erstandenen mft s3
stunden schrieb an dem bericht den sie
am abend abgeben musste dies tat sie am
liebsten auf einem herkömmlichen 2d
endgerät die arbeitsumgebung mit vr
brille hatte zwar den vorteil dass sie
die reale welt mit ihren ablenkungen wie
klingelnden handys oder einladungen zur
kaffeepause ausblendete aber an mochte
den trubel um sich herum
plötzlich erhielt sie einen anruf von
kevin ihrem smart home assistenten er
kümmerte sich in ihrer abwesenheit um
die wohnung und war für die organisation
des haushalts zuständig leider war seit
dem letzten update noch anhänglicher
geworden hallo an bist du fleißig am
arbeiten ja was gibt ich langweile mich
schrecklich wann kommst du nach hause
bald du weißt doch dass oskar und ich
heute abend bei freunden eingeladen sind
natürlich die mitbringsel sind gerade
geliefert worden nimmst du mich später
mit nein du bleibst allein zu hause
warum wir werden etwas für k s
vollkommen unmögliches zone am
lagerfeuer sitzen und uns unterhalten
so herzlich willkommen ab hier übernehme
ich mein name ist christine partie ich
bin journalistin und bedanke mich
natürlich für die einladung und auf den
auftrag des auftrags bei miriam gössner
und wenn ich
aussuchen könnte dann würde ich aus
theresa hanich text am liebsten folgende
inspiration übernehmen also ich hätte
ganz gerne den erwähnten filter mit dem
sie das empörungspotenzial
bestimmter debatten im internet kämpfen
lässt dann hätte ich gern ein inklusive
möglichkeiten natürlich die dort
geschildert wurden eines mitarbeiter
glaube ich nicht so richtig werk immer
der gleiche mann doch darüber reden ob
wir darüber wirklich schon in dieser
ausführlichkeit sprechen oder davon
träume oder uns davon befürchten können
und natürlich hätte ich ganz gerne den
smart home assistenten und alle meine
mitbewohner in um mich herum hier aus
dem raum auf ich würde sich auch freuen
wird es diesen smart home assistenten
tatsächlich geben es gibt vier punkte
die wir aus dem text in der folgenden
diskussionsrunde besprechen können und
vielleicht ist ihnen auch aufgefallen
dass wir in diesem text uns mit einer
welt konfrontiert gesehen haben sie
eigentlich relativ positiv gestimmt war
also die davon berichtet wie dieses in
dem so genannten digitalen raum sich
dinge weiterentwickeln die eigentlich zu
einem vorteil der gesellschaft und des
miteinanders gereichen ob wir so darauf
schauen können auf diese zukunft und was
man dafür tun muss und wie es eben um
die werte bestellt ist sie damit oder
die man dafür in technischen
entwicklungen unterbringen muss in
welche das überhaupt sind das wollen wir
jetzt gleich besprechen ich freue mich
sehr dass drei tolle gäste da sind dass
es einmal geraldine sebastian
politikwissenschaftlerin viele viele
aufgaben hat sie macht wie man kennt sie
vielleicht auch group aus der von der re
publica als moderatorin aber vor allem
auch als kuratorin mitgründerin und
geschäftsführerin des
beratungsunternehmens kollektiv herzlich
willkommen geraldine sebastian schön
dass sie da sind vielen dank freue mich
sehr dabei sein zu dürfen wir uns auch
außerdem ist dabei jessica heesen
leiterin des forschungsschwerpunkts
medienethik und von der universität
tübingen hatte vorher schön dass sie
auch da sind teile zusammen vielen dank
und dann ist noch dabei die hat
philosoph am lehrstuhl für metaphysik
und ontologie denn ludwig maximilians
universität in münchen und
vertretungsprofessor für praktische
philosophie an der uni konstanz hallo
hallo hallo vielen dank wir können
natürlich jetzt gleich diese einzelnen
szenarien die wir gerade gehört haben
abklappern aber mir war ganz wichtig
dass wir mit einer frage beginnen die
auch schon in unserer ankündigung quasi
implizit aufgeworfen wurde denn wir
sprechen über den digitalen raum und wir
sprechen glaube ich seit 20 jahren über
den sogenannten digitalen raum was immer
noch so also für mich den eindruck macht
wir hängen aus einer boris becker
schleife fest als würde immer noch da
reihen können und dann da wieder raus
gehen und dann würden wir in diesem
digitalen raum irgendwas tun und dann
uns schnell wieder in die analoge welt
begeben ich glaub mich so ganz an diese
abgrenzung aber rein sprachlich machen
wir sie immer noch sebastian arbeiten
sie noch im digitalen raum oder was ist
für sie überhaupt dieser digitalen raum
ja die verschmelzung dieser räume haben
wir natürlich irgendwie auch schon sehr
viel besprochen in den letzten jahren
aber auch sehr viel gelebt gerade
während der pandemie und das ist
natürlich auch was was noch mal sehr
schön diesem beispiel in dem text von
frau janine gerade geschildert wird wie
weiter auch diese verschmelzung der
digitalen räume und der analogen
passieren wird und wie viel intuitiver
diese übergänge in zukunft werden aber
ich glaube und vielleicht noch mal so
ein schritt zurück zu gehen dass der
titel unserer veranstaltung wirklich
perfekte geht es um den zustand der
digitalisierung in deutschland zu
beschreiben denn wir erleben ja diesem
rasenden stillstand exakt in diesem
themenfeld in unser aller leben täglich
das heißt auf der einen seite die
dynamischen technologischen entwicklung
und die überforderung die das auch
teilweise mit sich bringt für uns als
einzelne die informationsüberflutung die
komplexität der themen die auf uns
zukommen wie wir in zukunft unsere daten
verwalten und welche entscheidung damit
getroffen werden dürfen und auf der
anderen seite den stillstand also das
nicht weiterkommen zu entscheidenden
digitalisierungs fragen rund um
infrastrukturen rundum digitalisierung
der verwaltung die schlüsseltechnologien
die wir darum brauchen wie autos
zitierte bild aktivitäten schädigungen
im internet und wie wir uns sicher
ja sicher bewegen eben im internet die
ganzen ungelösten großen fragen mit
denen wir uns auch schon sehr sehr lange
auseinander setzen und diesen stillstand
eben auch sehr schmerzhaft in unserem
alltag leben vielleicht ein kurzes
aktuelles beispiel das was ich in den
letzten tagen sehr bewegt hat wie viele
menschen in diesem land habe eine
ukrainische gastfamilie und es war in
berlin ein sehr abenteuerlich habe
prozess eine anmeldung zu bekommen wir
waren unheimlich stolz und sehr froh als
wir den berliner verwaltungsgericht
durchdrungen hatten und im bürgeramt mit
einem papierzettel rausgehen und die
mutter der ukrainischen gastfamilien mit
ihren beiden töchtern die eder war
punkte diesen zettel an und freute sich
riesig und guckt nicht an an und meinte
es on paper
und war dann noch verwirrter als sie
verarbeitet hat das als nächstes ihr
einen brief per post geschickt wurde mit
einer plastikkarte
sozialversicherung und guckt ziemlich
ganz verwirrt an und mein traum
erwischte und ja wie gesagt das war ein
aktuelles beispiel dafür was mich im
moment beschäftigt das könnte man sogar
noch ergänzende um so zwei andere
beispiele glaube ich ist eine ist auch
ein bisschen twitter wissen aber dass
auch ukrainische schulkinder wird in
deutschland sind teilweise eben auch per
homeschooling auch in der ferne quasi
weiter unterrichtet wurden wo sich finde
ich nicht ganz unproblematisch dann
sofort so
menschen in deutschland darauf gesetzt
haben gesagt habe und bei uns war das
alles nicht möglich findet im vergleich
oder sich das hier ähnlich machen
bisschen schwierig aber natürlich auch
das in richtung digitalisierung oder der
von mir noch nicht ganz zu ende
recherchierte grund warum die
impfpflicht nicht möglich sei wegen
papier mangels unsere also kann man auf
jeden fall glaube ich aktuell viel in
den medien finden ich finde ukraine ist
ein wichtiges beispiel das kann ich ja
schon mal wegstecken auch dass ich
nachher auch unbedingt kommen möchte
weil diese ganze soziale social media
kommunikation und auch natürlich das
große thema dran da im moment auch so
aktuell ist dass wir das nicht umgehen
können gar keiner form selbst wenn wir
so positiv gestartet sind mit einer welt
in der zukunft in der das internet oder
die digitalisierung eigentlich für für
fortschritte im gesellschaftlichen
zusammenleben sorgt die sek lesen sie im
medienethik habe ich gerade schon
vorgetragen steckt in ihrer
berufsbezeichnung drin und auch an sie
die frage mit diesem sogenannten
digitalen raum bieten jetzt mal noch mal
nennen möchte also ethische fragen
würden sie sagen die unterscheiden sich
im digitalen raum eigentlich wirklich zu
den ethischen fragen die wir auch in der
analogen welt haben also sehen sie der
ausgewiesene grenze sobald man dann im
internet ist gibt es sie nun jeder sich
überhaupt keine grenze also die frage
ist ja immer wo handeln menschen und wo
werden menschen wirksam und das tun sie
in vermeintlich realen raum also da wo
wir physisch präsent sind aber das tun
sie natürlich auch in medien also zum
beispiel auch wenn man einen brief
schreibt sowie dass die frau die bastion
gerade geschrieben hat das sind alles
handlungen die wir ausführen indem wir
dann sagen du darfst dies oder das tun
wenn die verwaltung das macht oder wenn
wir telefonieren benutzen wir medium und
erzeugen dadurch handlungen genau das
gleiche machen wir eben auch im
digitalen raum das heißt wir
kommunizieren also menschen da man sagt
auch es gibt ein kommunikatives handeln
und das findet in allen ebenen statt und
da können sich menschen schädigen die
können gute dinge tun aber menschen
erzeugen ja einen eigenen kultur raum
also dass die gesamte sphäre des
menschlichen wo man sich über dinge
verständigt die geltung haben sollen und
das findet sowohl im digitalen raum
statt wenn man wenigstens dieses bisher
wir sind immer ne zwickten wir müssen
irgendwie diesen begriff benutzen damit
wir wissen wo vor gesprächen aber
eigentlich macht es überhaupt keinen
sinn da zu einer großartigen
unterscheidung zu kommen und natürlich
müssen wir uns danach fragen also gelten
die herkömmlichen normen und werte
genauso im realen raum wie digitalen da
muss natürlich sagen ja stellen sich
manche probleme eben anders da durch
diese medialisierung der kommunikation
durch die eigene logik eben auch dieser
sozialen medien der sogenannten und so
weiter aber natürlich gibt es da keine
großen unterschiede
ich habe gerade gehört mit dieser raum
fragen das geht jetzt gleich ein signal
ist es ja auch so es gab ja sogar noch
einen anderen eine andere beschreibung
für den digitalen raum das ist ja
neulich noch neuland also man versucht
anscheinend wirklich immer auch ein
sprachlich da viel hinzukriegen dann
könnte man im moment sagen so neuland
digitaler raummeter boers wer so eine
steigerung die sich da so andeutet wieso
haben wir denn das bedürfnis das
tatsächlich so räumlich zu beschreiben
um nahdistanz zu haben oder einfach weil
es das technisch es ist gut auch der
digitale ich spreche lieber von dem
virtuellen raum auch der hat eine
ausdehnung jetzt nicht nur physische
ausdehnung der ist nicht im fünf meter
lang fünf meter hoch aber auch da können
wir uns entfalten da können wir
handlungen vollziehen das stimmig fräsen
ganz zu also hier gibt es möglichkeiten
die wir entwickeln können und deshalb
durchaus die rede von einem raum es ist
eben der virtuelle raum ich fasse das
internet zum beispiel nicht primär als
medium auf in dem wir dinge konsumieren
information nur beziehen sind eben als
ein virtuellen handlungsraum wir speisen
in der das internet dinge ein wir
stellen verbindungen her im internet das
alles können wir sehr wohl im sinne von
handlungen verstehen aber eben nicht im
sinne von physischen handlung sondern
sinne von virtuellen handlung die in
einer anderen raumzeit logik reichen
entspricht im internet davon dass alles
viel reibungsloser vonstatten geht es
gibt so was wie ein onlive davon hat
luciano florida der oxforder internet
tätig finde ich sehr treffen also es
gibt schon andere bedingungen die dem
virtuellen handlungsraum konstituieren
aber im endeffekt würde ich vorlesen
zustimmen dass unsere werte die ihr im
physischen raum gelten auch dort zu
gelten haben aber sie stellen sich
vielleicht anderen problemen andere
probleme situation finden wir dort vor
und da können wir heute sehr gern noch
weiter diskutieren das ist sicherlich
eine ganz zentrale frage
wir könnten ja sowieso schon alle
freundin vor gesprächen festgestellt
ungefähr zehn stunden diskutieren jetzt
haben diese kleine stunde ich wenn man
zwischendurch kurz sagen wenn jemand aus
dem publikum gerne eine frage dazwischen
schieben möchte das was wir hier so
miteinander sprechen dann können sie das
jederzeit in den chats schreiben und es
landet dann bei uns hier auf dem panel
und wird auch beachtet und zweiter also
auch wenn sie es ein bisschen themen
unabhängiges von dem punkt an dem wir
gerade sind trauen sie sich ruhig sich
hier zu beteiligen ich habe versucht es
so ein bisschen jetzt für diese kleine
zeit zu unterteilen wir wollen über die
werte sprechen müssen kurz mal über
plattformen sprechen und die
kommunikations frage die ich schon
angedeutet hat und am ende müssten ja
auch wenn wir nicht den fiesen immer
wieder zitierten selbst denken selbst
sprechenden kühlschrank erwähnen werden
aber über smart home da komme nicht ganz
vorbei weil es wahrscheinlich die
nächste form der kg entwicklung auch ist
mit denen man sich im alltag auch als
normaler in anführungsstrichen mensch
beschäftigen will oder muss oder
vielleicht kann eines tages will nicht
unbedingt das kommt darauf an ich habe
ja schon angedeutet das besondere ist
dass wir es eben gerade so in der welt
bewegt haben mit dem text von theresa
hanich das eine ganz gute welt ist
jessica hier sind ihre forschungsbereich
ist die medienethik und auch die
werteorientierte entwicklung von ki ich
habe mich gefragt das klingt eben erst
mal gut als hashtag buzzword das mit den
werten um welche werte geht es denn
dabei eigentlich also kann man diese
große frage in kurz beantworten
aber ich kann einmal versuchen
verschiedene werte zu unterscheiden oder
auch zu sagen was man eigentlich
kritisch mitdenken muss also werte gibt
es eben für unterschiedliche bereiche es
kann natürlich auch ein wert sein im
wirtschaftsbereich besonders viel geld
zu verdienen zum beispiel das war jetzt
aber nicht unbedingt ein wert den wir
jetzt in der ethik sein erster stelle
auf dem schirm hätte sondern man würde
dann eher mal fragen was sind denn zum
beispiel allgemein anerkannte werte der
kopf ganz schnell auf die menschenrechte
zum beispiel oder mann fragt nach was
ihm zur ermöglichung werte das ist dann
zum beispiel die demokratie wenn man
sagt das ist etwas so gutmenschen sich
darauf verständigen wie sie leben wollen
wie sie handeln wollen also demokratie
wären ganz wichtiger wert aber insgesamt
ist natürlich bei dieser rede von der
wertorientierung immer die frage auf
welche werte kann man sich überhaupt
einigen und vor allen dingen welche
wette können die allgemeingültigkeit
anspruch erheben und da wird dann oft
eben ungemütlich also da haben wir
erstmal phase eins dann sagen alle ja
menschenrechte sind total wichtig und
natürlich auch demokratie im digitalen
aber dann ist natürlich die frage wie
kommt man dahin und da fängt es an
kritisch zu werden weil da gibt es ganz
unterschiedliche auffassungen dazu wie
man zum beispiel jetzt ki entwickeln
sollte was ist die beste lösung wie ich
wie stellt man transparenz her und so
weiter oder ganz unterschiedliche
politik modelle kommen dann zum tragen
um die sie über werte letztendlich zu
verwirklichen also man muss ganz genau
hinschauen wie bestimmt man die werte
sind sind die prozesse aber dann auch
wie füllt man die dann überhaupt in der
praxis und das haben wir noch lange
nicht beantwortet wenn es um
digitalisierungs fragen geht
sehr agilen de bastion in dem beispiel
von vorn mit der ukrainischen familie in
deutschland die auf papier irgendwie
angemeldet wird und so weiter da liegt
ja auch eine wertefrage vielleicht
könnten sieht also noch mal sagen auch
in den bereich in den dem in dem sie
sonst unterwegs sind also kollektiv also
zu versuchen irgendwie auch über
verschiedene plattformen leute sei es
für konferenzen und andere umstände
miteinander zu verbinden weil man kann
sie natürlich darüber lustig machen und
sagen was alles nicht digitalisiert und
es ist alles so auf papier aber
natürlich bedeutet das ja auch das
erreichen zu wollen eben auch was was du
dieser werte frage passt würde ich mal
sagen nämlich eben ist es nicht nur
praktisch sondern es hat möglicherweise
auch damit zu tun wie eben leute
miteinander verbunden werden die zugänge
geschaffen werden usw können sie dazu
ist noch ein bisschen ausführen weil ich
glaube dass ist wichtig zu wissen dass
wir nicht auf diesem vorherigen level
bleiben von hier klappt es immer alles
nicht und anderswo es ist toller sondern
es ist ja auch eine grundlage die
geschaffen werden muss für eine
gesellschaft noch mal andere
möglichkeiten miteinander hat ja
vielleicht zwei aspekte dazu ein
zentraler wert der für mich sehr präsent
ist in diskussion gerade um digitale
sanität und so die trend begriffe die
wir aktuell miteinander sprechen
buch bin ich noch das okay
entschuldigung kurzer internet glitschig
ist vertrauen vertrauen ist wirklich
eine der zentralen begriffe die im
moment sehr heiß diskutiert werden wie
wir dazu kommen in dieser immer
komplexeren gesellschaft vertrauensvolle
verhältnisse herstellen zu können gerade
in sich eingangs schon meinte der
abwesenheit zuverlässiger daten die wir
uns identifizieren im netz wie wir
transaktionen zwischen bürger und staat
organisieren aber wie wir vielleicht
auch zu mehr
transparenz und einem anderen
miteinander in unserer plattform übung
gekommen also wie können diese
vertrauensverhältnisse digital aussehen
und zuverlässig und sicher gestaltet
werden und das hat natürlich auch damit
zu tun irgendwie ich schon im meinte wie
wir miteinander interagieren und 20 nur
auf der inter personellen ebene also
wenn wir um zum beispiel fake news und
und mediale themen im netz sprechen
sondern eben auch gerade wenn wir
zwischen bürger und staat interagieren
was ist dann sicher ist der stempel auf
dem blatt papier sicher oder ist eine
digital unterzeichnete datei sicher also
wie schaffen wir dieses vertrauen und
diese sicherheit im netz wenn wir das
ganze global betrachten dann sollte aus
meiner sicht natürlich dieser fokus den
wir jetzt auch gerade in dieser neuen
legislaturperiode auf das thema digitale
souveränität haben nicht dazu führen
dass wir über nur regionale oder
nationale digitale strukturen nachdenken
sondern den wert der offenheit und der
globalen offenheit der etwas
grundlegendes im internet ist
beibehalten und weiter ausbauen und das
fand ich auch ganz ermutigend im
koalitionsvertrag zu lesen dass da ein
passus ist entwicklungszusammenarbeit
geht das ist ja auch ein fokus von
kollektiv der da heißt das digitale
souveränität und auch so verstanden wird
dass wir in einer gemeinsamen
zusammenarbeit und kooperation zum
aufbau digitaler strukturen mit anderen
ländern der welt zusammen arbeiten also
vielleicht auch ein bisschen diesem
werte und policy orientierten weg den
die eu gerade versucht zu gehen nicht
als wie man es manchmal sagt so
digitales kolonialisierung school zu
verstehen sondern als einladung an
gemeinsam weg zu gehen um eine
werteorientierte digitalisierung ein
aktives modell zu schaffen was aber eben
nicht nur ein europäisches ist sondern
auch eine gemeinsame globale
unternehmen unterschiedlicher
demokratischer länder und regionen
kann man denn
grenzen überschreitende werte dieser art
wie gelatine bastian gerade geschert hat
das hinkriegen in einer welt die analog
immer noch grenzen orientiert
funktioniert online aber eigentlich ja
nicht also nehmen jetzt mal aus dass
natürlich wiederum einzelner staaten
hallo welt zu regulieren et cetera aber
einfach mal jetzt erst mal grundsätzlich
das eine was eine abgeschlossene
gemeinschaften darstellt welches das
internet das dann aber dort auf einmal
gemeinsame werte sucht ist eine ganz
wichtige frage das internet ist eben
kein nationales phänomen kein lokales
oder nur regionales phänomen und ein
globales es wurde ganz richtig gesagt
wir treten alle im internet reibungslos
miteinander zusammen so dass räumliche
und auch zeitliche distanz nicht mehr
diese rolle spielen die sie in der
analogen welt spielen und ein wichtiger
wert der mich ganz zentral zu sein
scheint vielleicht der zentralste wert
ist ja der freiheit der menschlichen
freiheit das heißt wir sollten im raum
der digitalisierung nicht
technokratischen zwängen unterliegen
also wir sollten den übergang schaffen
von der digitalisierung im sinne der
bloßen technokratie der bloßen technik
vielleicht auch im sinne der bloßen
medialität hin zu einem virtuellen
handlungsraum zu vollziehen wenn wir die
digitalisierung im sinne der
virtualisierung verstehen also der neuen
ermöglichung von freiheiten die wir
vielleicht so noch nicht kannten dann
schaffen wir es unsere freiheit und auch
unsere würde zu vergrößern weil wir
nicht mehr lose gegenstände und objekte
der technokratie der technik sind keine
bloßen daten ansammlung sondern weil wir
selbst autonom mitbestimmen wie dass wir
mit unseren daten tun wollen und wie wir
auch im internet als autonome subjekte
agieren wollen also das scheint mir ganz
wichtig ist seine freiheit im virtuellen
raum gegen klose technisierung die plose
für objektivierung zu reinen daten
ansammlungen
frau die bastion die ist das eigentlich
weil wir sehr den den
nächsten politik bezug wahrscheinlich
moment hier in dieser runde haben also
mit forderungen dieser art & vision auch
dieser art als ich meine vision
überhaupt nicht abfällig sondern so wie
eigentlich die zukunft dann auch
aussehen sollte und dem gerade schon
erwähnt neuland und der schwierigkeit
auch in deutschland mit digitalisierung
an vielen stellen und zu gehen wo sie wo
stehen wir denn jetzt eigentlich dann
gerade also ich bilde ich den nächsten
punkt komme ich gleich zum metallbörse
ich weiß gar nicht ob wir darüber jetzt
reden sollen weiß ich insgesamt nicht ob
das wirklich das ist worüber wir
sprechen müssen aber das klingt
natürlich sehr weit entfernt dafür dass
wir uns sonst auf politischer ebene an
ganz anderen ende der entwicklungs und
diskussionsmöglichkeiten über
digitalisierung befinden
wie viel zeit haben wir noch nein also
recht und mit dem letzten punkt des vita
wer sonst kurz einzusteigen ich hatte
letztens einen täter wechsel zwischen
michael seemann und new yorker
mitgelesen der amüsant und erschreckend
war in dem sinne dass sie sich beide
darüber beschwert haben dass sie nur
noch presseanfragen zum metaversum
bekommen und alle wichtigen digital
politischen themen um 4 grad ist ein
bisschen unter teppich gekehrt werden
das ist natürlich irgendwie auch ziel
das sozusagen schon medialen
ablenkungsmanövers das uni das spacebook
olibet also dass der des unternehmens
meter was versucht hier einfach in ein
anderes licht zu treten und natürlich
sich auch einen anderen medialen raum
wieder zu erarbeiten
und ja auf der anderen seite sind es
natürlich auch spannende technologische
entwicklung von virtualität ja auch im
text von training angesprochen wurden
darauf können wir vielleicht noch mal
eingehen die tatsächlich auch ja zu
erwarten sind dass sie auch große sowohl
positive implikation herausforderung mit
sich bringen aber ich bin es auch stehen
dass sich der text zunächst erstmal auf
die positiven möglichkeiten verstärkt
hat zu der frage wo stehen wir gerade es
ist sehr schwer eine kurze antwort zu
geben denn auf der einen seite ist es
natürlich toll so viel aufbruchstimmung
zu sehen und alle haben sehr viel
hoffnung natürlich gerade an diese neue
regierung
und vieles macht natürlich auch ein
bisschen
sorge wenn man sich jetzt betrachtet wie
die einzelnen themen aufgeteilt werden
in den einzelnen ressorts und wie viel
reibung dann natürlich wieder wie viel
stillstand letztendlich auch wieder
gerade zu beobachten ist das ist jetzt
aus binnen sich der ministerien besteht
ungefähr das zu sagen aber von der
außenlinie sich her der digitalen
zivilgesellschaft schon der zustand
vielleicht auch da natürlich wieder
kommen sehr unterschiedliche dinge
zusammen ich hatte ja schon mal um 16
prozent ge und wie sehr wir damit hier
gerade in berlin kämpfen erwähnt auf der
anderen seite passieren denn natürlich
auch
wichtige dialoge die den raum für diese
diskussion ermöglichen in ministerien
ich werde gleich friend linkedin zum
zukunftspreis des bmbf wo ich sehr froh
bin dass ich da teil daran haben darf
das bmbf macht regelmäßig foresight
prozesse wo sie versuchen diversen kreis
von personen zusammen zu bringen
unterschiedliche forschung ströme von
umfragen die gemacht werden studien die
geschrieben werden workshop mit
unterschiedlichen science fiction autor
innen um wirklich nochmal anderen
offenen blick auf zukünftige zu werfen
diese auch zu teilen wie gesagt das
ganze wissen was daraus gezogen ist auch
öffentlich zu teilen um zu gucken wie
man andere
gesellschaftlicher dialoge außerhalb des
alltäglichen
tagesgeschäfts ranges führen kann und da
fand ich es wirklich super spannend zu
sehen dass auch viele von den punkten
die frau haniel text aufgegriffen hat
auch wirklich aktiv die themen sind die
wir in diesem zukunftspreis diskutieren
vielleicht können wir da auch noch mal
gleich darauf eingehen ich fand zb
besonders spannend die betrachtung zu
den unterschiedlichen beziehungs typen
und wie die sich in zukunft verändern
werden also vereinbarkeit von beruf und
familie
oder wie viel vielleicht mit unserer
home ki beziehungen pflegen
das stimmt und das ist ja noch einen
hund und gott ich denke ich würde sagen
wir klammern dann tatsächlich auch das
meterweise ein weil ich habe genau diese
vorbehalte natürlich auch selber
wahrgenommen weil genau das und die
flussmündung in meta passierte als ein
paar unschöne dinge aus dem facebook
universum zu tage traten und prompt gab
es da diese die sind diesen fokus darauf
es macht spaß glaube ich aus deswegen
wahrscheinlich presseanfragen an den
erwähnten michael seemann und co das
weil man es spaß macht sich diese welt
vorzustellen man sich jedes mal vorkommt
als wenn man in so ein zukunftsroman
aber gut es nur in klammern dazu gesagt
ich hab mal kurz jetzt wie ich das
erwartet abkommen fragen rein und zwar
die passende ich immer ganz genau zu dem
programm gerade sind es macht aber
nichts jessica heesen vielleicht zuerst
eine frage gibt die sich zweimal oder
zwei fragen ähneln sich sehr nämlich
wäre heute die werte eigentlich für den
digitalen raum festlegen die politik
eine art ethikkommission oder die
allgemeinheit und darunter gibt es eben
noch mal genau wie kann man ein
wertekodex für die kommunikation dann
noch ein bisschen spezieller im
virtuellen raum etablieren vechta
nächstbesten dafür zuständig eigentlich
diese ist an die wirklich nix dabei also
politik ethik kommission allgemeinheit
oder wissenschaft oder alle zusammen
wir können gerade noch mal das beispiel
von dem roller aufgreifen also freiheit
als zentraler wert würde ich unbedingt
unterschreiben also gerade auch als
medien ethikerin auf freiheit der presse
und natürlich der information und so
weiter wenn wir jetzt so ein beispiel
uns anschauen dann ist es natürlich die
frage wessen freiheit ist denn
eigentlich gemeint also geht es jetzt um
die freiheit der wirtschaft und um die
ausbreitung der plattformen industrie
ich komme gleich darauf war das
regulieren soll oder ist es jetzt
freiheit der einzelnen netz nutzerin und
dann auch die freiheit dazu hate speech
zu verbreiten oder
ist es eben die freiheit der information
sich jetzt aus freien quellen zu
bedienen aus dem internet zum beispiel
haben wir ganz unterschiedliche arten
von freiheit und dann ist die frage wer
ist dafür verantwortlich einmal wir
natürlich für vieles verantwortlich für
mein eigenes handeln zum beispiel es
geht meine freiheit nur so weit wie die
freiheit des anderen eingeschränkt wird
ich darf also eigentlich kein hate
speech verbreiten und damit andere daran
hindern ihre meinung frei zu äußern im
internet da muss ich mich sozusagen
selber fragen wie möchte ich selbst
behandelt werden das sind dann solche
dahinter subjektiven
ideale die dann letztendlich da auch zum
tragen kommen oder da können auch so was
die netikette kommen also gar keine
regulierung von jets geben auf der ebene
gibt es daneben denn der versuch diesen
wörtern durchzusetzen aber dann auf
höherer stufe wenn man fragen wissen
freiheit jetzt zum beispiel bezug auf
internetkonzern konzerne da erwarte ich
natürlich eine eine freiheits
regulierung durch die politik jetzt zum
beispiel durch die europäische
kommission den tischen services act und
so weiter also die infrastrukturen
müssen reguliert werden damit wir
bestimmte werte umsetzen können damit
wir möglichst viel freiheit erlangen
können muss es eine regulierung geben
das ist erstmal ein scheinbarer
widerspruch aber also funktion in der
demokratie da würde dann also die
politik zum tragen kommen oder es gibt
natürlich dann auch noch viele andere
ansätze zum beispiel so was wie
regulation bei infrastructure oder
privacy by design values indesign er
sagt man die systeme sollen technisch
schon so aufgebaut sein dass bestimmte
werte verwirklicht werden können das zum
beispiel
diskriminierungsfreiheit herrscht oder
eben auch barrierefreie zugänge also da
gibt es ganz viele unterschiedliche
möglichkeiten werte umzusetzen die waren
gar das kann man gar nicht beantworten
jetzt ist nur die politik oder nur der
einzelne oder die einzelnen zuständig
sondern ist ein ganzes paket
natürlich immer daher weil es so ein
bedürfnis gibt irgendwas zusammen zu
fassen wie fast wie so eine hausordnung
die natürlich aber genau auf einer
analogen welt auch schon überhaupt nicht
für alle funktioniert noch mal die
speziellere frage wie kann man ein
wertekodex für die kommunikation im
virtuellen raum etablieren vielleicht
möchten sie das noch ergänzen dollar
also kommt immer auf die und hab dann
sind ja vielleicht eigentlich schon
genau da wo wir eigentlich auch aktuell
noch mal hin müssen wenn wir uns die
also die möglichkeiten kommunikation in
social media
eskalieren zu lassen oder sie komplett
einzuschränken oder sie mit propaganda
falls zu werfen wie aktuell anschauen
muss ganze ist ja gar nicht so schwer
fallen halt russlands aber zumindest
wenn wir auf diese entwicklung gucken
wie kann man denn da ein wertekodex
etablieren der dann auch noch dazu
grenzenlos funktionieren könnte das ist
glaube ich total naiv das zu fragen aber
den wertekodex für kommunikation kann
uns doch mal genauer anschauen das ist
eine ganz wichtige frage ich persönlich
vertrete immer die meinung das ist doch
am ende von uns einzelnen individuen
abhängt wie wir den raum der werte auch
im digitalen gestalten mir scheint dass
wir den freiheits raum der virtuellen
welt selbst vergrößern oder verkleinern
können das scheint mir ein sehr großer
wert zu sein vergrößern wir durch unsere
handlungen im virtuellen raum zb das
internet den raum der möglichkeiten oder
verkleinern wir ihnen wir verkleinern zb
durch fake news wir verkleinern den raum
durch das dark nett wenn wir uns
abkoppeln
also ganz wichtig wäre diesen raum so zu
vergrößern dass ein öffentlicher diskurs
ein idealer weise gleichberechtigte
diskurs von allen nutzerinnen und
nutzern möglich ist und in diesem
zusammenhang wäre ganz wichtig so was
wie medienkompetenz
medienkompetenz als tugend im virtuellen
handlungsraum des internets jetzt aber
nicht verstanden im sinne wie viele
stunden pro tag darf er jetzt am
computer sein damit es keine sucht mehr
wird sind medienkompetenz in der frage
wie kann ich den virtuellen
handlungsraum vergrößern wie kann ich
vermeiden dass einzelne nutzerinnen und
nutzer zu bloßen objekten von
ökonomischen interessen werden dass die
zu bloßen objekten von künstlicher
intelligenz werden zu bloßen
datengrundlagen reduziert werden also
wie können wir unsere subjektivität
unsere individuelle autonomie im
virtuellen handlungsraum den wir selbst
auch vergrößern und verkleinern können
aufrecht erhalten das scheint mir ganz
wichtig zu sagen
geraldine sebastian davon auch
medienkompetenz sagen im jahr 2022 für
das auch hier meines podium so ein
bisschen aufzustacheln
man muss es immer wieder sagen und immer
noch genauso laut und ja das ist genau
auch wieder zurück zur frage wo stehen
wir heute nicht hatte vor zwei tagen
diskussionen zum thema safer internet
day auch digitale souveränität wo es
auch viel um bildungsfragen gegen und
immer wieder dieselbe frage warum ist
das noch nicht integriert und unseren
schulunterricht und deutschland warum
führen wir dieselben diskussion zum
thema digitale bildung die wir ja vor
der pandemie und schon viele jahre
vorher geführt haben also ich kann einem
wassereimer gesagt hat gerade nur
zustimmen genau und ja ich
hatte nur gerade ein paar notizen
gemacht weil es so schöne statements
waren mit dem virtuellen handlungsraum
vergrößern ich hoffe das hat jemand
getwittert und auch schon die nächste
frage die gerade angekommen
soll ich da noch eine oben damit in der
mitte die wollte ich noch mal kurz die
nicht übersehen haben ich muss dir mal
vorlesen weil ich habe sie beim nebenbei
dieser nicht ganz selber nicht kapiert
haben sie zum folgenden erfahrungswerte
der nutzen und die herausforderungen
beispielsweise datenschutz der ki in der
betrieblichen weiterbildung als auch die
förderung zu kompetenzentwicklung das
geht glaube ich an frau heesen
soweit ich das nach also aber ich habs
gerade vorgelesen weil ich verstehen sie
die frage schon gleich komprimierter als
ich sie jetzt also ich hab jetzt gehört
dass es um die betriebliche
mitbestimmung geht und ich habe es auch
nicht so ganz verstanden aber ich kann
ihnen sagen da gibt es schon einiges was
da diskutiert wird also zum beispiel
kann ich da in ihnen empfehlen das forum
soziale technik gestaltung von herrn vom
dgb obwohl schon relativ viel dazu
ausgearbeitet wurde wie man umgehen soll
im betrieblichen alltag gerade in bezug
auf die betriebliche mitbestimmung mit
algorithmen gesteuerten arbeitsprozessen
und ein künstlicher intelligenz es gibt
auch das chaos serwa thorium im
bundesarbeitsministerium wo auch zu
solchen themen gearbeitet wird
beziehungsweise zur denkfabrik heißt es
auch im bundesarbeitsministerium also da
gibt es schon einiges aber es ist
wahnsinnig schwer alles zu
operationalisieren und erwarten wir
natürlich auch noch auf die
entsprechenden ausarbeitung zu diesem
themenbereich und wir haben insgesamt in
diesem bereich auch noch mal die
herausforderung dass wir natürlich schon
ganz viel in der sogenannten industrie
40 haben was mit digitalisierung läuft
aber dass letztendlich sehr weit
entfernt von den arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmern entschieden wird also das
sind dann fabrik abläufe wo dann die
einzelnen menschen dann nur noch die
subjekte sind die sich irgendwie
verhalten müssen innerhalb dieser
intelligenten fabrik und jetzt gerade
erst beginnt ist nach meiner
einschätzung dass man sieht dass es da
auch viel mehr mitbestimmung geben muss
auf arbeitnehmerseite
die kamen nochmals zu recht die
anmerkung aus dem publikum dass man
zwischendurch aus des metallbauers hätte
mal erklären können das ist allerdings
richtig ich versuche es zumindest sie
dürfen sich gerne ergänzen wenn sie wenn
sie das besser können als ich gerade mit
meinen wenigen worten aber das metall so
die idee digitaler virtuellen raum zu
erschaffen indem man sich eigentlich
egal ob man dort gerade seiner home
office arbeiten verrichtet oder ob man
dort chattet oder ob man dort an
konzerten teilhaben kann sich komplett
aufhält so will ich das meinen kurz
erzählen des metallbörse die idee die
jetzt nicht von von mark zuckerberg oder
facebook alleine kommt also daran
arbeiten verschiedene plattformen
unternehmen aber mag hamburg hat eben
vor kurzem jahr facebook bzw also
facebook in meter als firmenname
umgewandelt um natürlich nochmal viel
näher an diesem metaversum zu sein indem
verschiedene entwickler sitzen verdient
gerne ergänzen
das war wunderschön erklärt das ist auch
genau dafür wie facebook diesen raum
eingenommen hat nicht denn wie du gerade
schon gesagt hat dass es ein begriff der
aus einem science fiction roman kommt
und eine technische entwicklung an der
video gerade gesagt hast
unterschiedliche arbeiten ich hatte ihn
auch ein link rhein gegeben dass es auch
open source meter wersen ideen gibt
dynamic line zum beispiel also was was
er aus dem ccc umfeld heraus wächst mit
einer ganz anderen idee wie solche räume
aussehen könnten die vielleicht dann
nicht nur
digitale kommerzielle räume sind um noch
bessern unsere daten und unsere
geldbeutel zu kommen vielleicht eine
ganz kleine ergänzung noch machen weil
das sonst wird sich das ja so vollkommen
aus der zukunft an das ganze aber wenn
man sich solche sachen anschaut was aber
jetzt gerade gemacht hat nämlich dass
sie weitere haben von sich produzieren
lassen also von ihrem jüngeren ich die
jetzt auch auftreten also das ist
sozusagen so ein vorgeschmack dass es
viel von technologie da einfließt wie
man dann letztendlich von sich selbst
ein abbild schaffen kann und übrigens
gibt es in dem bereich jetzt auch schon
bestrebungen menschen die schon bereits
verstorben sind wieder zu erschaffen
also dann avatare eben als
repräsentanten im virtuellen raum
entstehen zu lassen und das gibt es
schon alles auch in ansätzen eben in
kleinen diensten also oder in die das
ganze meter wird eben erstellen sondern
eben wie diese titel afterlife industrie
zum beispiel dann die angebote machen
oder eben für die unterhaltungsindustrie
war aber
nun vielleicht kennen sie viele noch das
holodeck aus dreck und haben damit ein
bisschen vorstellung gefühl wie das
metaversum aussehen könnte und wie ich
gehört aber werden jetzt aber schon
grundstücke im metaversum teilweise
verkauft also es gibt sozusagen
natürlich einen hype darum der dann
wiederum in der kleineren klasse
zunächst mal stattfindet aber genau wie
vor hielten aussage also das ist es
fühlt sich so futuristisch an arbeit man
genau überlegt was passiert es gibt es
in anteilen findet es sozusagen schon
stadt ist aber natürlich auch ein großer
also tatsächlich sage auch ein großer
hype eben der ausgelöst ist von dem
großen facebook unternehmen vielleicht
davon noch einen schritt weiter die
frage richtig sowieso richtig war dass
man ordentlich zu erklären und dann aber
eine frage aus dem publikum vielleicht
ähnlich daran anschließt wie kann es
eigentlich gelingen alle in der
digitalisierung und der ausgestaltung
mitzunehmen vor dem hintergrund dass
eben nicht alle zugang technisch oder
persönlich zu digitalen medien haben das
würde auch noch mal mein anfrage von
freie widersprechen wo ich so getan habe
als er das so toll wenn wir alle so toll
digitalisiert wenn du dir nur dass
teilhabe und zugänglichkeit ermöglichen
stimmt natürlich nicht wenn man bedenkt
dass es nicht alle auf demselben stand
sind da hab ich dann gleich eine sache
sagen denn ich finde wir machen
digitalisierung in deutschland und
vielerlei hinsicht falsch wenn ich mir
angucke wie es in anderen ländern
ausgestaltet wird weil wir uns nämlich
die chance für schnittstellen nehmen
statt diese auszugestalten und ich finde
das sieht man in so vielen beispielen
meine bankfiliale in tegel hat gerade
geschlossen obwohl hier fast
ausschließlich 14 personen wohnen die
bestimmt keine digital native online
banker sind ja und stadt daraus jetzt
sind digitales terminal zu machen würde
auch meinen dass eine große
bankgesellschaft sich vielleicht noch
ein angestellten leisten kann
und da eine gelegenheit schafft um
menschen heran zu führen als online
banking zum beispiel das wäre doch mal
was oder die landesbibliotheken hier in
berlin haben schon vor einiger zeit im
senat und forscher gemacht dass sie auch
als schnittstellen führung gehen können
um da digitale bürger services
anzubieten so was wird ausgebremst stadt
gefördert einmal geschaut länder wie zum
beispiel ruanda wo es schon seit vielen
jahren verpflichtend ist seine
steuererklärung digital abzugeben aber
natürlich nicht jeder mensch zugang zu
digitalen technologien hat kein heim
anschluss hat vielleicht nur ein handy
und ein laptop gibt es daneben
öffentliche kiosks wo man hingehen kann
und gemeinsam unterstützt seine digitale
steuererklärung abgeben kann und ich
weiß nicht warum wir in all den vielen
möglichkeiten die wir in diesem land
haben nicht mehr auf eine menschlichere
digitalisierung setzen und diese
schnittstellen ausbauen ja da würde ich
gerne anknüpfen wir nicht darf das geht
so ganz in meine richtung ich glaube wir
sollten immer mehr dahin kommt das
internet als eine art von grundbedürfnis
anzusehen vielleicht sogar auch als ein
grundrecht was an jedem menschen zu
kommen sollte sei es jetzt in der vom
französischen kinos die grad genannt
wurden von solchen knotenpunkten zu dem
man sich hin begeben kann sei es das ist
durch satellitenübertragung ein
flächendeckendes angebot gibt mir
scheint eben das internet ist nicht nur
medium sondern es ist insofern
grundbedürfnis oder auch eine
grundstruktur die erst dann ganz andere
prozesse erlaubt wie zum beispiel
bildung wie zb auch die verbesserung des
medizin systems wenn ich zugang zu
wissen habe und wenn ich eben nicht nur
das internet als ein passives konsum
medium ansehen sondern auch als ein
aktiven gestaltungsraum also ich glaube
da gibt es noch interessante politische
dimension in die vernichter mich das
recht auf internet-zugang haben sollte
weil internet eben mehr ist als nur
informationssammlung sind weil das
internet ganz neue dinge ermöglicht wie
gesundheitsversorgung bildung usw es ist
also so eine grundstruktur wie fließend
wasser wie elektrizität
und also jetzt ein bisschen polemisch
frage aber das ist doch wirklich
erstaunlich weil genau das das sozusagen
ein grundbedürfnis auch ist und vor
allem nicht nur in deutschland sondern
eben auch wie sie es gerade alle
beschrieben haben innerhalb der welt wie
lange müssen wir das jetzt noch
besprechen also bist du bist das ankommt
und man nicht diese diese großen spalt
spaltung ist spaltung ist zu viel gesagt
aber diese großen unterschiede auch
machen müssen zwischen ich habe doch
keinen zugang ich kann es nicht und den
anderen die sagen die so ist es noch
nicht so weit mir ist fast nächstes zu
langweilig und zu schwerfällig alles
also ich würde es einfach nur ein
bisschen auf die spitze treiben weil
natürlich diese grundbedürfnis frage ja
auch selbst weil sie nicht das weiß
vielleicht sebastian als repubblica
kuratorin seit wahrscheinlich gefühlten
20 jahren 15 jahren oder wenigstens
sehen jahren immer wieder im raum steht
ja und auch in einigen anderen ländern
ja bereits auch schon verankert ist
gesetzlich das ja es ist auch eine
us-bank jährige ließ sich sehr viele
fragezeichen und frustrationen auslöst
ich glaube dass wir einfach politisch
viel zu lange viel zu viel brach haben
liegen lassen nichts wurde sehr viel
gearbeitet was finde ich den großen
konzernen raum gelassen hat und
gleichzeitig wenig raum geschaffen hat
für digitale zivilgesellschaftliche
akteure und auch digitale wirtschaft in
deutschland und in europa und das ist
jetzt einfach zeit dass umzukehren und
andere eben auf offene systeme auf die
zentrale systeme auf unsere
werteorientierten policy getriebenen
systeme zu setzen und hoffentlich zu
viel mehr auch eigene innovationen oder
auch eigenen digitalen räumen
wiederzukommen nicht also das ist ja
auch was das wir gerade wieder ganz akut
sehen auch leider aufgrund des krieges
wie schaffen wir andere
andere digitale räume wo wir uns auch
kulturell begegnen können wo wir ein
menschliches austauschen miteinander
fördern kann und da vielleicht auch eben
ja andere gemeinsamkeiten schaffen
können als es mit den social media
plattformen des letzten jahrzehnts
gelungen ist
dadurch vielleicht doch noch was dazu
sagen
tatsächlich möchte ich gerne dass auch
nochmal aufgreifen also die ich möchte
das auch sehr gerne unterstützen oder
unterschreiben auch was frau die bastion
unterhändler gesagt haben in bezug auf
die defizite in bezug auf medien
mündigkeit ob das alles nicht voran geht
und ich selber arbeite ja auch zu dem
thema wie kann man die digitalisierung
eben wertorientiert vorantreiben und gut
gestalten aber jetzt trotzdem noch mal
wenn wir uns gerade den freiheitsbegriff
anschauen dann müssen wir uns ja schon
ehrlich machen und sagen was ist er mit
der freiheit derjenigen die eben
digitale medien nicht benutzen wollen
und jetzt zu sagen alle müssen dahin und
so eine art totalität aufzubauen der
digitalisierung das kann noch meiner
auffassung auch nicht die richtige
lösung sein denn man muss sich auch
bewusst machen sobald man im internet
ist wird man überwacht also ich möchte
jetzt nicht sagen also ich find s
internet toll aber ich muss ich finde es
muss menschen geben die sich die
freiheit nehmen zu sagen damit will ich
nichts zu tun haben und dann ist
natürlich die frage muss man jetzt für
die wenigen die dann noch übrig bleiben
vielleicht mit gutem grund also muss man
da parallelstrukturen aufrechterhalten
muss es vielleicht doch noch irgendwas
auf papier geben wenn wir uns auch noch
mal anschauen ich habe die rolle hat
noch mal gesagt elektrizität ist also
internet ist wie elektrizität oder
digitalisierung das kann alles ausfallen
gerade wenn man es jetzt anschauen wie
die wie die weltpolitische lage ist wenn
wenn es keine elektrizität gibt dann ist
auch nichts mehr mit digitaler
kommunikation also daran muss man auch
mal denken bei aller euphorie in diesem
zusammenhang gegen auch das thema
resilienz immer wieder ein sehr großes
thema in einen zukunfts forschungs und
federn ist und auch in diesem bmbf kreis
vielleicht gerne plädoyer halten führt
das was man eine digitale aufklärung
nennen könnte also ich glaube wir
brauchen eine digitale aufklärung die
ganz streng unterscheidet zwischen der
bloßen technologie der technik der
digitalisierung die für viele
befremdlich sein kann wie fräsen sehr zu
recht gesagt hat wo sich viele menschen
auch überfordert fühlen können und was
sie als ein fremdkörper ansehen können
und ich glaube wir müssen wegkommen
müssen versuchen bildungsarbeit zu
betreiben eine digitale bild bildung zu
entwickeln die dann führte dass man das
digitale nicht mehr nur als etwas
technisches äußerliches ansieht sind als
ein lebens wirklichen faktor der sich
nahtlos in alle bereiche einbeziehen
lässt wie es auch die elektrizität für
100 oder noch mehr jahren war die jetzt
auch eigentlich jeder akzeptiert ich
glaube nur ganz wenige wollen wieder
zurück vor die elektrifizierung und so
scheint es mir ganz ehrlich zu sein mit
der digitalisierung es geht aber nicht
nahtlos und nicht unmittelbar auch nicht
von oben vor geordnet vorgesetzten jeder
mündige bürger muss man selbst autonom
ein verhältnis dazu entwickeln im sinne
der digitalen aufklärung ich plädiere
dafür digitalisierung nicht
technologisch zu verstehen sondern sie
eine virtuelle realität im sinne der
ermöglichung neue freiheiten und das
betrifft eben alle von uns
dann muss man leider dann auch sagen
dass wir also mit den vorbehalten gegen
nürnberg zu der tat das finde ich auch
gut dass sie das auch mal gesagt haben
das ist ja eben auch noch mal dieser
andere perspektive gibt und die rührt
ihr wahrscheinlich auch daher weil
natürlich denken dass jetzt noch nicht
einmal der digitalen raum das internet
natürlich beherrscht es von den
plattformen und diese ganzen datenschutz
und überwachungs problematik natürlich
daher würden und es nicht geschafft
wurde
parallele andere netzwerke zu schaffen
und so weiter also dass dass er so eine
kapitulation ist so entweder die einen
sagen okay ist mir auch egal ich mache
damit oder ich ich kenne mich gut genug
aus oder ich kann da auch ich kann das
alles nutzen und ich kann es positiv
sehen und dann gibt es eben die gruppe
die sagt ich will kann das nicht
einschätzen und ich möchte auch dass
eben alles nicht ist denn da noch
irgendwas zu machen also danke ich
glaube es gab sehr viele versuche allein
wie gesagt im sozialen netzwerk bereich
überhaupt parallelstrukturen an so
starten natürlich hat gar nichts
funktioniert weil keiner die möglichkeit
hatte so in dieser größe überhaupt
existent zu sein dass man sagen kann da
uns seid ihr in sicher also sind die
sicherheitsfrage ist ja auch eine
persönliche bestimmte er fühlt sich wohl
wie sicher es ist jetzt alles schlimm
oder nicht muss jeder für sich wissen
aber natürlich ist klar was die probleme
sind in dem von der macht der plattform
bestimmten digitalen brauch aktuell ich
bin da der ewige optimist und die ewige
optimistin und ich finde da ist noch
sehr sehr viel zu machen und da passiert
auch gerade sehr viel was mich positiv
stimmt ja ich glaube schon dass wir das
wieder an einen dieser kritischen
momente angekommen sind wo wir schauen
wie stellen wir jetzt eben die weichen
um nicht weiter an diese historische
digitale zukunft zu rennen sondern in
einer etwas wünschenswertes und eben
einen weniger von den big five oder
bestimmten plattform logischen
dominierte und da sind die policy
vorstöße über die frau heesen freundin
schon gesprochen hat von europäischer
seite die sed mmk ii verordnung sehr
sehr wichtige rahmen die gerade
aufgestellt werden das wachsende
bewusstsein dass wir vielleicht einen
seltsamen das internet gerade für uns
geschaffen haben was in kleinen silos
funktioniert wo nicht mal die daten bei
uns liegen also sprich statt der
interoperabilität der frühen jahre egal
welchen e mail client ich habe wir
können uns gegenseitig e mail schicken
zu dieser app welt im internet gekommen
sind wo nichts mehr so richtig mit
ändern da sich austauschen und reden
möchte auf der technischen ebene dass er
wieder wegkommen müssen hin zu einer
ente opera blr in welt die wir auf
datenstandard beruht so dass auch ich
sag jetzt mal technische dialoge über
grenzen hinweg wieder anders möglich
sind als es heute der fall ist in zu
einer welt die mehr auf open source
technologien setzt um ressourcen zu
sparen und zwar sowohl ressourcen in der
physischen welt also
klimaschonend zu sein aber auch
kapazitäten und gelder zu sparen da
passiert gerade sehr sehr viel und da
ist schon ich würde sagen hoffentlich
ein kleiner bewusstseinswandel im gange
und deswegen auch meine hoffnung dass
wir da eben diese weichen ob
entsprechend stellen können
welche ist das ja auch so eine erzählung
frage oder es gibt noch eine frage aus
dem publikum nicht gleich mal unbedingt
noch stellen weil ich da aber ich habe
gerade überlegt weil natürlich war oder
ist digitalisierung ist ich kann es nur
speziell in deutschland sagen natürlich
auch immer wieder zu recht auch erzählt
worden über die sorge vor der
überwachung über die sorge vor den
ganzen daten probleme usw
mit viel ist nur auf weil jetzt diese
erzählung des eingangs dieser
veranstaltung natürlich sehr positiv
strukturiert war es gibt glaube ich
jetzt erst langsam überhaupt auch weil
sie nicht literatur et cetera und dinge
die auch mal von der anderen seite des
internet erzählen also am anfang große
euphorie man kann es den größten
wissensaustausch die große soziale
zusammenführung auf ganz vielen ebenen
dann breakdown alle stellen fest dass
jedoch gar nicht so ist auch ein
bisschen gefährlich und vielleicht ist
jetzt auch ein bisschen zeit dafür
wieder auf andere punkte zu gucken oder
wäre das naiv was meinen sie also klar
die optimistin hat gerade schon
gesprochen auch natürlich die damit
entwicklungs und politische optimisten
aber tatsächlich auch auf die art und
weise wie wir uns erzählen was dieses
internet kann waren war das vielleicht
ein bisschen zu sehr düster an vielen
stellen oder zu wenig ambiguität
tolerant
freundlich
ja ich bin auch ein optimist was das
internet angeht eben im sinne des
virtuellen und möchte auf wikipedia
verweisen auch wikipedia ist sicherlich
manchen hinsicht problematisch was die
bedeutung der autorinnen autoren angeht
die regionale globale verteilung dass es
nicht ganz gleich verteilt aber
wikipedia ist für mich ein gutes
beispiel dass wir möglichst frei
kommunizieren können dass wir ohne
ökonomische interessen wissensbestände
aufbauen können wikipedia wird ständig
aktualisiert wikipedia hat gewisse
standards der informations überprüfung
ist nicht perfekt das ist klar aber ich
will zu hause kein 20 bändigen brockhaus
mehr stehen haben der alle zehn jahre
veraltet sondern ich will den direkten
unmittelbaren zugriff auf die artikel
haben und ich möchte auch sehen wie so
ein artikel zustande gekommen das heißt
ich möchte transparenz sie möchte hinter
den artikel sehen und schauen welche
versionen es gab welche diskussionen zu
diesem wissens bestand beigetragen haben
und wenn ich das nachvollziehen dann
komme ich eben auch selbst zum wissen
und nicht wenn ich nur ein brockhaus
aufschlage und aus einer seite etwas
lese ich möchte wissen wie der prozess
des wissens stattgefunden hat und das
erlaubt mir eben so was wie wikipedia
was völlig unabhängig von ökonomischen
interessen ist und das ist für mich ein
vorbild und das könnte sich noch einen
ganz anderen hinsichten weiterentwickeln
im medizinischen bereich in sonstigen
bildungssektor
11 entwicklung könnte man da auch noch
nennen aber das für den zweck so ist es
wird zu detailliert ich will man die
frage aus dem publikum noch stellen ich
weiß jetzt schon unsere abschlussfrage
ist gucken wir mal wie lange die
antworten sind wie sehen sie denn im
hinblick auf die zunehmende
digitalisierung des verhältnisses
menschen zur natur bei dem es bereits
eine starke entfremdung gibt und es
klingt erst mal wie eine internet
feindliche frage ist aber dann nochmal
ergänzt und die stichworte umwelt und
klimaproblematik ressourcen verbraucht
co2 ausstoß durch das digitale
vielleicht heesen an dieser stelle also
die genau diese sind ja da sind ja auch
fragen drin wie man sich von der einen
in die andere welt bewegt und wie sich
dann verhältnisse vielleicht auch
tatsächlich verändern können ja da fühle
ich mich tatsächlich auch als technik
philosophischen angesprochen auch bei
den fragen nach der frack bei der frage
nach der natur also das ist ja so dass
der mensch ein kulturwesen ist der
technologien braucht sozusagen als
natürlicher bestandteil also das ist ja
so konsens sagen wir mal dass der mensch
eben ohne technologien gar nicht leben
kann und umso wichtiger ist natürlich
dass er sich diese
technologie so dass er die so nutzt das
sie für ihn selber als menschen optimal
sind aber auch natürlich für die natur
und es kann immer nur sein dass solche
technologien auch den nachhaltigkeits
kriterien entsprechen müssen damit wir
uns nicht unsere eigenen
lebensgrundlagen ja berauben also
insofern
technikgestaltung ist eben auch immer
gesellschaftsgestaltung und die natur
gehört auch dazu das ist ja ganz klar
also wir kommen einfach nicht da
drumherum uns zu fragen ob wir
ressourcen schonend zum beispiel auch
wirtschaften im bereich der
digitalisierung und jetzt sind wir schon
so viel von medien mündigkeit gesprochen
haben oder was sind werte die wir
vertreten da muss man immer sagen
irgendwann klappt man eben der laptop zu
macht das handy aus und macht was
anderes also es geht ja immer auch eine
pluralität der erfahrungs weisen und das
finde ich auch einen ganz wichtigen wert
übrigens in unserer werte diskussion
dass es immer wieder eine pluralität
geben muss also von vier verschiedenen
verschiedenen erfahrungs weisen
verschiedenen diensten verschiedenen
medien usw das ist ein ganz wichtiger
wert in diesem zusammenhang
darf ich noch ganz winzig ergänzen und
zwar jetzt die stimme natürlich einem zu
und war auch sehr spannend gerade
zuzuhören ich hoffe auch wieder die
ewige optimistin das ist ein neue chance
für ein anderes miteinander zwischen
mensch und natur geben könnte und dass
wir politisch natürlich digitalisierung
und klimaschutz einfach als gemeinsame
aufgabe denken müssen und das ist eben
gegebenenfalls in den besseren verstehen
und unsere umwelt durch andere daten
durch andere einsichten durch ki
verarbeitete daten ja einfach auch in
anderen zugang für menschen wieder zur
natur gehen kann und ich fand das
schönste beispiel was man letztes in
einer naturdokumentation begegnet ist
dass wir vielleicht bald wahl sprechen
können und ich glaube das ist ein sehr
großes weiterkommen für die menschheit
wäre wenn das so wäre und wir uns recht
auch anders mit anderen speziellen auf
diesem planeten verständigen könnten
jetzt ist schwer zu sagen ist das
schlusswort oder nicht weil es gibt noch
eine letzte frage aber die da auch die
dafür neue antworten wenn sie das in
einer minute schaffen aber ich finde die
so gut weil das so abrundet wie kann man
denn überhaupt digitale kompetenzen
weiter denken wenn es nicht gleichzeitig
eine ethische kompetenz gibt also
vorausgesetzt glaube ich sehr auch eine
zugespitzte frage wenn wir das in der
analogen welt schon nicht so richtig
hingekriegt haben wir reden jetzt auch
der ebene darüber sie haben nicht mehr
so viel zeit wir wollen pünktlich sein
aber ich könnte es vielleicht auch noch
schön am abschluss zum abschluss das mit
einzubeziehen es scheint mir davon
abzuhängen dass wir digitalisierung als
virtualisierung verstehen also als
eröffnung von neuen freiheit und
handlungsräume und wenn wir eben
digitalisierung im handlungs
theoretischen aspekt verstehen dann sind
wir gleich bei der ethik dann geht es um
die frage wie handeln wir mit den
digitalen medien wie handeln wir handeln
wir in ihnen und durch sie und dann
stellen sich die frage nach gesetzen
nach der frage wie man die räume
vergrößert wie man andere person
respektiert wie man sich der vollkommen
digitalisierung durch ökonomische
interessen entzieht wie man sich schützt
also digitalisierung sollte man immer
als handlung als performative und gehalt
ansehen und dann sind wir gleich
politischen fragen
da wird noch mal gelegt in der runde
dass wir nicht einen schönen abschluss
haben wir heute gar nicht weil ich
gesprochen seine eher digital ist
zumindest so ein bisschen ich bedanke
mich sehr für das also bei allen
natürlich die hiermit diskutiert aber
auch bei allen die zu gehört haben und
die uns die frage in den chat
geschrieben haben das ist immer toll
weil es natürlich die moderatoren
entlastet aber vor allem auch so ein
bisschen
austausch in dieser runde bringen eben
leider immer noch in diesem remote
zustand oder auch für manche sehr gut
guter weise in dieser digitalisierte
version stattfindet das haben wir gar
nicht gesehen aber sind froh dass sie
alle da waren in der nächsten woche geht
es weiter und da ist die überschrift
daten gläsern für den guten zweck
fragezeichen dass es am nächsten
mittwoch wiederum von 12 bis 13 uhr zu
erleben können sich online anmelden und
wir bedanken uns für die aufmerksamkeit
und wünschen ihnen noch einen guten
restlichen hoffentlich sonnigen tag
vielen dank bis bald tschüss alle jazz
podium
[Musik]